[Applause]
and the spirit award for best
documentary
goes to
summer of soul
or when the revolution could not be
televised
[Applause]
[Music]
thompson's first spirit award nomination
and win
and it's his directorial debut
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you for this honor
it took a village of people to free
this film from its 50-year sentence
sitting inside of a basement
it starts with the dream of two
gentlemen
in harlem tony lawrence and hal tolson
it starts with 300 000 beautiful
residents of harlem
it starts with all the musa jackson
hello brother
oh damn all right you came on stage
um it starts with all the all the
artists that played but
um thank you to everyone involved from
hulu
to searchlight to the beautiful women of
onyx we can't thank you enough for this
uh
concordia
vulcan play action um
just
robert david uh our friends at radical
everyone that
i'm so
i'm not gonna cry right now i'm not i'm
not uh
david
david i'm sorry
joseph
man this is
this this guy wrote my first cover story
for rap pages 25 years ago and look at
us man we're like
living the dream restoring history
bringing black joy to the world
um
everyone that worked so hard josh
pearson thank you very much for for your
your editing magic uh
uh
so many am i missing someone that that
we should
oh oh my god how are you doing i'm sorry
we're all at the same table but
yeah
andrea yes i said everyone thank you
very much and also to
i also want to and that everyone in this
category really deserves a round of
applause it was hard in hell
for everyone
it
it
it was so hard for people to
tell stories and bring joy to the world
in such a tumultuous time and that's
what real artistry is i know that all of
us
have this thing where like the world's
burning outside but we're in here
celebrating and you know for artists
it's it's it's very hard to
to push forward so i thank all the
people in the category that made this
happen thank you film independence